this week's classic interview is very
much related to the upcoming election
and it's very very much related to an
article I read earlier this week I think
I mentioned this on the Monday show
there was an article I believe in New
York magazine which argued that it's
really great that Hillary Clinton can go
into much more political depth than
Donald Trump but her wonkiness may not
serve her that well because we have such
a politicized status quo in this country
which is very very attractive to many
people that Hillary Clinton being able
to go into depth on issues may not
actually be that appealing to many many
voters and that's exactly what I
discussed with Peter Coleman back in
January of 2014 this interview was very
relevant then given the struction ISM
political stagnation that was existing
between House Republicans and President
Obama at the time and it is very
relevant in sort of understanding what
we're seeing now we're in in a normal
world in an ideal world I don't even
know what adjectives to assign to it at
this point in a world that made more
sense to me any reasonable person would
see Donald Trump and Hillary Clinton and
say this is not a question no matter my
political beliefs Donald Trump is just
fundamentally not qualified to be
President of the United States but
because there is thus attraction to the
politicized and polarized status quo of
our country this this duopoly that we
have uh someone like Donald Trump
actually could be President of the
United States so let's get to my
interview from 2014 with Peter Coleman
i'm joined today by Professor Peter
Coleman he's professor of psychology and
education at Columbia University also
director of the international center for
cooperation and conflict resolution and
author of the five percent finding
solutions to seemingly impossible
conflicts let's start professor maybe
with that title who are the five percent
that you describe the five percent comes
from some research that looks at really
international conflicts over about a
200-year period and what researchers
have found is that if you look at
all of the conflicts that have taken
place really between states and nations
in that time a very small percentage of
them about 5% of them get stuck into
kind of an ongoing very polarized
destructive dynamic that sometimes lasts
40 50 60 years or more and they are
unresponsive to typical attempts to
resolve them diplomacy mediation
negotiations they there's some evidence
that those types of strategies you
actually make them worse so it's those
five percent of conflicts that we study
in the international domain but we also
see evidence of these types of dynamics
that take place in the in domestic
relations and political dynamics here in
the pro-life pro-choice conflict in some
communities etc so okay so that that
gives us a sense so I I guess you kind
of started to answer what was going to
be my follow-up which is speaking
domestically you talked about pro-choice
pro-life what other issues would kind of
fall within these seemingly intractable
conflicts domestically well I mean they
can happen in families often times you
know there is a dispute between siblings
between parents and children that that
become protracted and really people feel
constrained by and really see no way out
there are instances in new york city
where I live where you'll have a couple
that will need to divorce but stay in
the same apartment because it can't
afford another dwelling so they get
stuck into this kind of negative dynamic
and they're trapped because they can't
physically leave so those are the basic
conditions and they happen again in
families that happen in communities they
happen in you know universities they
happen at our university where you'll
see an ongoing dispute columbia
university where i teach has had an
ongoing dispute organized around the
israeli-palestinian intentions but on
campus where Israeli students or Jewish
students feel discriminated against by
certain professors and and so those
types of dynamics can play out
domestically as well as in turn
thinking about so-called kind of
partisanship in the context of American
politics since the Civil War have there
been changes in the amount of so-called
bipartisanship or the two sides that the
Democrats and Republicans working
together over time or has it been
roughly the same ya know there has been
considerable changes there again there's
data on this over several generations a
couple of centuries going back to before
the u.s. Civil War and the data looks at
really whether Republicans Democrats
will cross the aisle and support a
bipartisan bill or support a bill
proposed by the other side and what we
found is that politics today in the
United States in terms of voting
behaviors of Republicans and Democrats
are more polarized and they have been
since the u.s Civil War so we've become
increasingly more polarized in our
inability to have the politicians sort
of come together on consensus on
solutions to issues and that the the
current trajectory the current trend
towards more polarization started around
nineteen eighty that's when we really
started to see more and more
polarization but yes today it's it's it
um the voting patterns are more
polarizing then really ever before in
history certainly back as far as the UH
the Civil War one could make any number
of analyses about why that might be and
I want to throw a couple of ideas at you
and see if you think either neither or
both have some validity some people
email me and they say the reason why we
don't get anywhere is it politically
between Democrats and Republicans is
because there are only Democrats and
Republicans there is this two parties
duopoly status quo and that the
injection of some viable third-party
would shake up this it's either one or
the other kind of alternatives in force
pull up politicians to to work together
to create more alliances there's another
side all together which emails me and
says it's not so much about a third
party but it's about
it's kind of like a game theory
discussion where there's almost no
advantage to elected officials to be
bipartisan because they've got their
next election to think of they raise
money in in great part because of
because of these partisan issues that
you talked about are either of these
have kind of evaluate the either or both
of those ideas yeah I think they're both
valid issues there is an incentive
structure that keeps politicians focused
more on short-term gains and being
reelected or moving into ideological
beliefs and seeing compromise as the
enemy there are there are in fact many
good arguments for why we are as stuck
as we are what we believe is that it's
really some combination of all of those
things that creates basically a set of
constraints on politicians that really
trap them and force them to sort of
behave in a certain way that's
consistent with the you know the
structure of the system so what does
that mean that means that even though
politics in this country could be the
polarization of politics could be traced
back to things like gerrymandering to
money in politics the impact of lobbying
to religious beliefs or two more
fanaticism you know to sort of the
extremes both parties driving the
parties all of those things are valid
arguments but what we believe is that
somehow these things have sort of come
together and support each other in
complex ways and so that even when one
of these strategies one of these issues
one of these drivers of the polarization
drops away or is addressed or somehow is
you know effectively remedied it doesn't
seem to have an impact on the on the
patterns the patterns still stay stuck
and that's because they're multiple
terminals why they are stuck in this way
and a lot of the typical solutions that
people try to introduce don't seem to
have much impact I know that at the
State of the Union not this year but a
couple of years back they congressman
decided to sit not across the aisle from
each other for the student union
sit next to each other right there was a
lot of ridicule regarding that strategy
but what that reflects is the fact that
there is this change in the culture of
Washington where it used to be that
politicians would move their families to
DC and their families would go to school
together and their kids would hang out
together and they would have other kinds
of contact other than the sort of
disputes that they would face daily and
that allowed them that created a
different kind of dynamic between them
that was more reasonable and more
conciliatory and that's changed and so
this attempt to sit next to each other
during the State of the Union was some
attempt to begin to reconstruct how
these political actors interface but let
me just say one other thing if I can
because it's easy to see the divisions
in DC because we can count votes we can
see the political rhetoric coming
particularly from the extremes of both
sides but this is reflective of our
country of where we are in our personal
lives most of us in in the media that we
watch in the opinions that we hold in
the parties that we go to in the really
more exclusionary nature of our social
dynamics this is really a bottom-up
process and the population of this
country really need to take as much
responsibility I believe as our
leadership very quickly one other thing
I want to just kind of throw in is when
you talk about the bottom-up approach do
people have a desire to find simple
explanations for political issues in one
example I'm drawn to is the language
around tax relief is something that has
been very effective for the american
right in the sense that hey if lower
taxes are relief that's very simple more
taxes are bad less taxes are good when
the reality is a very nuanced Shades of
Grey argument that is neither more
videos net neither a ton nor is it no
taxes but people seem driven to simple
explanations yeah that's absolutely true
i think under difficult circumstances
difficult economic times under
threatening times such as post 9-11
people are anxious and they do want to
have a sense of sort of simple solutions
provided by their leaders but
by governments and they latch onto those
and so you know political operatives
understand this they understand that if
you frame something that resonates with
people's fears concerns basic needs that
they'll latch on to it and they'll
support it even if it's only half
correct but there are other
organizations in this country that sort
of try to counteract that I mean the
media to some degree some media to some
degree will try to provide more of a
balanced perspective on these issues but
there are also dialogue forums such as
the national issues forum which I would
recommend your viewers go to they have a
website and they try to present the
nuance of a lot of these more
complicated issues the this sort of gray
area and say that it you know we're not
we're not trapped by the polarized
dynamic that there are there are
solutions there are strategies that that
are more informed by the complexity of
these problems we've been speaking with
Professor Peter Coleman professor of
psychology and education at Columbia
University check out the five percent
finding solutions to seemingly
impossible conflicts really a pleasure
having you on thank you David thank you
very much